okay everyone this is the order flows
Christ rejecter indicator how to
determine when the market is rejecting
price and how to profit from it I'm
going to look at various charts markets
and timeframes my name is Michael vatos
i'm the founder and trader at order
flows calm first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capitals
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing once financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading anyway those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
what is the price rejecter it's an
indicator based on order flow analysis
to determine when the last buyer has
bought and the last seller has sold the
price rejecter uses order flow analysis
to identify low-risk trade entries at
potential turning points in the market
mainly highs lows swing highs and swing
lows the price rejecter runs on the
NinjaTrader software platform it's easy
to use just import into ninja trader and
trade it's designed for an order flow
footprint chart but now has been
programmed to work on a normal bar chart
there's no PhD needed no live trading
room needed basically you just plug it
in and go so I'm going to show a bunch
of different charts and timeframes over
periods of time rather than just pick
one chart you know the cherry pick chart
you know i'm going to show you winners
i'll show you losers not every trade is
going to be a winner no system out there
guarantees 100% winners okay so the
first chart is a crude oil chart is this
is june crude the date is May second you
know the first trading day of May and
I'm going to go over a few weeks of data
you know the data that I have saved and
you know specially they said i know i'm
going to show you all pretty much you
know every time trained cat signaled and
you know what
wins or loses and you could determine
yourself how you would trade it now my
crew chart here is I just talked about
the i have what i call mike's index
hours which is basically seven in the
morning chicago time until four o'clock
you know and usually that's when I trade
as some keys and you know for me you
know that that's when the market I think
most markets American markets are the
most liquid okay so this is a union
wrinkle chart okay now here 726 was a
buy you know it asking the first trade I
show you is a loser it's unfortunate
here you get a cell it comes off a
little bit just where the hangs around
doesn't really go anywhere unfortunately
it is down here here's another sale sell
go sideways before stopping you out you
know you should have in your trading you
have to have stops you know there's
there's no two ways about it now this
price rejecter will give you levels that
you can put a stop you can put your stop
right up at this hash and you can go a
little bit higher it depends on you your
entry is going to be in the next bar the
signal will generate when the bar meets
the condition so as soon as it meets the
conditions in the bar it prints however
if it changes before the bar closes the
signal can disappear but once the signal
is drawn it won't disappear won't we
draw so here you know it starts come off
a little bit then just sort of go
sideways and you know it does pop up
through before just go in sideways some
more and you know you got to determine
what amount of risk and what sort of
profit potential you want are you
willing to risk a little bit here you
know this is I said this is a wrinkle
chart you know just look at the
crosshairs real quick shouldn't put you
know you know ideally if you get short
around the entry at the next bar you
know 4514 your stop is going to be up
around here 21 you know that I prefer to
give it a look like and ticks you know
because usually i'm trying to get a lot
more out of the trade than 10 ticks but
you know if you want to use a tight stop
right up here where this hash is you can
it's up to you and you know what
profit target do you want you know
people trade all different ways you know
people trade multiple contracts and they
start taking some off as it starts going
in their favor and they look for you
know a runner okay so this one you know
it started going down you know just sort
of hung around you know they really go
anywhere and I'm not gonna say is a
winner I mean even know it was I think
he could have got something out of it
you know I did come back up your poke
through there and then sort of go down
this one definitely is a loser now this
one here you know you can be getting
short here 45 40 never took much heat
and you know if the market just had a
nice sell off from 45 40 down to 44 60
so you know what is that ed ticks or
last mean I don't know if you would have
gotten on the entire move you know maybe
sort of come down here pop up a little
bit you want to take some off okay it's
up to you then you get another buy
signal down here goes up from you know
this 65 level up to double oh you know
before turning back down a little bit
you know you're going to trail your stop
I mean you know entry and exit you know
you have to have a you know know how to
make part of being a traders is knowing
when to get out of the trade when you're
taking too much heat okay so you know
it's a nice winter here nice winter here
this one is looser this one is a loser
okay and the day ends until is the next
day may third you know again I'm using
you know this period of time for several
weeks of May because that's the data
that i have here most recent any signals
nothing yet here's a buy it kind of
works out a little bit before starts
turning on you again you know if you
were gonna have us going to have a stop
hard stop right there or what it's up to
you you know you gotta decide that how
you're gonna are you gonna trade it you
know i'm not saying this is a Holy Grail
to training you know it's it's helping
you find potential turning points in the
market now sometimes you know the market
maybe hasn't reached its it's low for
the day you know it's hard to find the
low sometimes it takes the market a bit
of searching before it finds a low or a
high or swing high so here
this one fails and you get another
signal right here okay you know 4370
4375 was it do trades down you know down
into the 40's you know this is already
coming on to a clock in here so you know
you you could have gotten a nice move
out of this right here so you know you
have a loss there you know maybe a small
winner you know maybe you know or you
know break even or even as a small loss
sir I mean I don't know how you trade
that I mean I know I would but you know
I'm not you okay here's another one this
is the fourth of May here's a signal
here but you know it's right after the
open and I'm always I tend not to take
things within the first you know there's
what I call a look-back period i think i
would set to nine so I'm not usually not
looking to take trades within the first
nine bars because what's doing is its
it'll cover the previous day's nine bars
as well so yeah normally i wouldn't take
this trade you know it was a loser this
one kind of small winner before turning
around becoming a loser on you nothing
nothing there I mean sometimes you know
the market just you know the order flow
doesn't give you you know in any any
trades okay here's his cell and you're
talking 4415 no came down here 4385 you
got a buy signal which failed you guys
sell signal again it failed come off you
get this buy signal here kind of going
sideways you're coming up towards the
close already I mean it did pop up you
know the old closing time for crude the
old floor clothes thats there used to be
210 chicago time so you know i mean once
you started coming into the one o'clock
you know careful it's going to often get
quiet but you know the market still open
usually after to even though it's open
beyond 2 i'm not necessarily looking to
trade so you know it picks this low here
43 30s kind of going sideways on you
before finally popping up honestly i
will go in sideways on me like this I
probably would have just gotten out
somewhere in here
rather than waiting going into the
closed but you know hey it was a nice
trade you know I know some people say
yeah you could have bought here carried
on to the next day I wouldn't do that oh
I wouldn't carry those you know that you
know proceeded to trade overnight much
higher but I mean you know that that's
not what I do so here's a cell signal
this is the next day this is the fifth
of may sell signal here 45 that is 70
you know down 45 35 ish the buy signal
going sideways cell signal comes off a
little bit know where my down here okay
you know this by signal failed you know
you like every signal to be a winner but
sometimes you know I said the market
thinks takes a while to find it slow
here is a small you know a small winner
before starts turning around when you
start seeing you know this is a wrinkle
chart when you start stringing together
red bars one after the other it's
usually not a good sign that move up is
going to continue just as you know you
again you know you got a better yet a
bullish signal but then you got red bar
red bar that's not necessarily what you
want to be seen here's one you know
again it's it stopped you out time is
this this is just before two o'clock I
don't know if I would take that again
you know I tend to stick to the old
floor closing times okay this is a cell
again this one failed here you gonna buy
and you know 95 up two of the 30s no are
you willing to risk it to ask yourself
are you willing to risk this you know
this little risk in here for a move like
this you know I would okay here's a cell
failed you're just here to buy it kind
of worked out and you know started turn
around on you i think i know that would
have been a scratch at best my day ended
a little early that was non-farm
payrolls here's monday the ninth yeah x
goes up before it starts turning around
you know when you see started seeing red
bars on the way down get out don't wait
for it to stop you out he was a by again
same
green green green and red red red here's
a by you know went from 4410 up to the
30 area before you got a cell signal and
then it sold off back down to 44 double
oh okay so you had another body you get
to buy the cell by here you know this is
a small move 2030 tix under again yeah
yeah you know sometimes you know people
think that every signal that you get is
going to go to infinity you know not
every trade is going to go to infinity
you know Venus a good trader is about
knowing you know managing your risk and
knowing when to get out take profits and
to take losses I mean you're getting you
know legitimate decent moves and you're
getting a chance right for you know 10
ticks initially here 10 tix here 10 tix
here you know 10 tix here you could get
a little bit more just as you get more
out of it you know it's if you keep
treating multiple lots there's different
ways to trade you know you take some off
you know as soon as it starts going in
your favor you know you booked profits
and overall you know the goal is the
have more profitable trades than then
losing trades hang on here charts are
acting up now give me a sec
okay so you know you know this one right
this was that net rate I just moved it
forward right so he came off from 4430
down to 4400 back up to 44 30 you know
that's 36 down 36 up and i'm not saying
you'd be getting out of here but you
know when you get this move right and
you start seeing you know a nice move
and you start seeing red candles it's a
sign it the the move is probably over
here green green green and also the red
red red you know anything do you gonna
wait for it to come all the way down
here to take take a take a loss no I
mean you got a part of training is
understanding what's happening in the
market you know you get in here 4395 you
know trades up to 44 15 and then also
you see red red red you know get out you
know you have to wait for it to come all
the way down you know part of the
problem with with a lot of traders
especially new traders and I spent a lot
of time talking to new traders and you
know they struggle in recognizing that
the markets turned you know they think
you know I'm getting along here I want
to get out way up here you know they
think the whole the tour going to hold
it to the close hold it to the next day
you know you're not it's it's a
short-term thing you know you're trying
to pick highs and lows swing highs and
swing lows so the markets going to move
around and sometimes you know the
markets not going to find its exact blow
or exact highs it's going to take some
time to move around before it gets it
you know hear you had a bicycle yeah the
market went up didn't you know it's
still searching for it slow here you
know made another low yeah it did rally
off it you know there was no signal here
here you got a signal but then the
market is still searching for word it's
it's level it's low level okay there's
no signals here you know there's one
right before the clothes you know which
is that not not a time I'm looking to
take a trade at 2 15 to 14 ok this is
the next day this is uh May tenth 510
you got a cell signal here 43 you know
8043 985 around there it comes down to a
buy signal here six around the 70 level
so you know that's that's 15
in 20 ticks there abouts it's a decent
move you know this one this buy signal
didn't work out it would stop two out
scroll for see any more signals know so
there's no more say well you know my eye
and they or at least I don't have the
rest of these data there okay so this
next day is May 11
course not you know as I'm making this
video my computer has the audacity to
start acting up on me but you know I
want to show you the sequential each day
as it's happening I don't want just pull
out yeah I could easily just pull out
charts of every trade that work done you
know and did not necessary show you the
losers but I'm trying to show you over
over a period of time each day and is
how it develops of course I need my
system to cooperate this is my testing
system so it's it's not as it's not as a
maxed-out come as far as you know
available ram and things like that still
it was working nice earlier right now
it's just sort of acting up on me
yeah so just look into the next signal
here
okay hopefully now it's working i had to
close something down and so this is you
know the 11th incredibly was a wednesday
so you know this move is part of the
inventory numbers if i remember
correctly how the calendar in front of
me though
okay so here's a cell signal right you
see it up here on 45 60 it didn't pan
out again it didn't work but you know if
can he have to be trading with stops no
I wish there was a nice buy signal right
before that big move up but there wasn't
you know i mean but i'm showing you the
winners i'm showing you that lose at
least i'm showing you everything here
here's one it just went sideways on you
again you got one you know honestly
though this is that look at the time 11
you know this is 0 time this was 11 15
say i won't even say that maybe 11 20
and she's going sideways on you for
almost you know 30 minutes are you going
to be holding a position that's going
nowhere on you for a half hour 45
minutes no I wouldn't you know it again
I when you're looking for a reversal you
expect the reversal to happen not go
sideways on you often times when you
sort of come into an area and instead of
getting the reverse it just goes
sideways on you you know it could really
go anyway either way as far as I'm
concerned it's it's just something that
doesn't always work out once the market
you get a signal and anything and just
go sideways on you especially you know
if it's a reversal signal right you
expect the reversal to happen well
you're trading a reversal signal and if
the market just going sideways well you
know even though it's not a big loser
it's just hanging around your entry sort
of break even as far as I'm concerned
it's a trade that's not working out so
this is what day is this this is the 12
there's a couple signals it started to
work out boom boom and within it turned
around but seeing these green candles
here again is assigned to tell you hey
you should think about getting up don't
let it come back here and stop you out
just as you got it here to green I sorry
to read then I know three green don't
you're gonna let it go stop you out I
wouldn't I mean it's the heart of
trading is making decisions
I know we all like to automate things as
much as possible but sometimes you're
going to automate yourself out of a
trade or out of a small you know a break
even trade rather I'll say I'll automate
yourself out of the trade so here's one
you know this one yeah it kind of worked
out you know you got red then green
green it's up to you if you get out
right here or not you know just sort of
assess it but you know eventually did
you know it's coming into that you know
sort of the the two o'clock time it's
ready 1 30 I you know me personally I
probably have gotten out here after you
know two green bars but that's me so you
know that day the twelfth wasn't that
great day Friday the 13th here is this
day that we're looking at see if there's
any signals okay there's a cell signal
right there sort of in the middle you
know I think I'd as soon as she gets the
signal you got green green you know that
that's not a good sign screen green you
know that that's something that would
stop you out probably at your full loss
okay here's a buy signal again it's just
going sideways on you boom boom boom
boom honestly I'm not gonna look to hold
it you know it was if you just go in
sideways on me you know I expect the
move to happen you know here it did
happen a bit later but they know that to
me that they'll see that that's too late
here's a signal again it's right you
know after the open I prefer to get you
know a little bit further away from the
open rather than you know sort of
immediately after the open you know even
though this one didn't work out that
it's probably not one it's it's honestly
probably it's not one that I would take
even though I could say well yeah I
would've taken it but you know I'm not
looking to take signals that close to
the open okay here's 10 time is this
this is you know oh just about one
thirty in the afternoon again you know
210 is the close but it's a nice move
45-47 55 56 57 58 somewhere in there
you know up to up to the 90 level and
one day's ok this is 17th this is ready
the third week of the month here has a
nice by you know 4775 ish area up to you
know to a cell signal at 4810 up here
you know that's what is that 35 tix you
know then you get a cell signal starts
come off boom boom boom the near Green
Green Green you know a lot of people
will say you know they'll see this and
they'll see that these green green green
and you know after they've trained
already moved in their favor you know
they're sort of will overlook this I
know you can't can't you know things
have changed you know its market
starting to go back up you know there's
people that you'll get the cell signal
here then you know get short here have
all this move down here and then you
know wait for to come all the way back
up here to stop them out you know you
gotta the mark is going to give you a
chance to get out with a small profit or
get something out of the trade you know
you really you know honestly I think you
it's not good training to sort of not
get something out of a move like this
and you know have it pull back like that
okay so you know what happened so we
only hold back and you trade back up to
your ear you know where your stop area
is up there but like I said you know you
got you getting short here on the way
there's at 4810 roughly you know it
rains down to 4795 before so you can
Green Green Green let's giving you a
chance in here you see this green green
you know by this third bar you see it
coming back that's a sign to get out and
you don't have to wait for it to go all
the way up here to to stop you out then
here you get a buy signal okay you know
the first bar after it is red but then
now it's green green green so it's it's
you know going the way you know the way
you expect it you know you get in here
somewhere around this 4810 level it
always trade up to 48 30 and then starts
come down you and get red red red that's
a sign that's the sahel that that's
telling you hey okay now the mark is
gonna start coming off you know everyone
expects
you're gonna be buying here and selling
up here it's not like that market moves
there's mony want kaulitz I can't think
of the phrase now you know what you get
the intermediate waves in there ok
screen is acting up again sorry to do
this is again this is the 17th which
book may say I think I should just keep
it scrolling
okay so now we're on the 18th okay I can
see there's a cell signal there just
creep it into the screen so here you got
the cell signal you're getting short
somewhere in here 48 double 4855
unitrans down to this 4830 level silence
decent move now again I don't know if
I'd be holding it into this area once I
start seeing you know three like that
you know i was just going sideways on
you well it's nine-thirty ok so again
it's it's the 18th I think that was also
Wednesday so you know even though as a
signal i think that was due to the
inventory number that came out I
probably wouldn't they I i would like to
say yeah we're taking it by aussie you
know when the inventory number comes out
you get a signal like this you go into
cell again you know you're thinking
you're selling here you're actually
selling down here if using a market
order because the markets moving too
fast for you to to really get a good
reaction time said you got to be a robot
in that sense
okay so here's another cell signal is
around the 48 87 level yeah it did come
back up here pop-up else nya again I
can't say that I would not have had to
stop in I probably would have been close
to stop felt if not stopped out
depending on your entry you know i like
to use about 10 ticks 10 Texas is 95
I said you know if you want to use a
little bit wider you'd be in for a nice
move okay so you get a buy signal down
here you know around the 48 05 level
trades up to 20 s sort of hanging around
hanging around you could have got a
little something out of it on skype i
get out once i see these three green
candle as I those three red candles and
you know it's just sort of coming into
the clothes there and the 19th i think
this is my last day I data that I have
okay come on be a lot easier if I system
wasn't acting up this this recording so
nothing in there that was a 10 10
nothing nothing no lies no cells you
know that's it that's what my data and
so you've seen you know quite a bit of
charts yeah Papa I have to make a
different video for different markets i
wanted to show a bunch of markets at
once but I think my system is I need to
close some stuff done I got too much
stuff open uh you know just real quick
overview price rejecter runs on ninja
trader trading platform it works on the
order flow of traders charts as well as
normal bar charts I think get the most
out of it you should use order flow of
trader charts works on just about every
futures market and timeframe so you know
if if you want to know more check out
the website WWF lows calm or visit my
website price rejecter calm so thanks
for watching this and I'm going to make
another video soon with different
markets probably the e minis so stay
tuned thanks bye bye